think of where we are today if people
don't really even know the skills they
have
or the skills they need just having a
simple baseline with some target skills
brings us so much uh further than we
ever have been
before
[Music]
kelly palmer welcome to my show how are
you
i'm great michael thanks so much for
inviting me today
i'm honored to have the former vp of
learning of
yahoo and the chief learning officer of
linkedin
and in general a world expert on this
art of learning
upskilling and but not just you know in
in a college academic environment or in
school but you know in the workforce in
a place where
we are assumed to have already harnessed
her skills
coming in and just you know just act
upon them but but you're actually saying
no no
we actually need to adapt because now we
have to upskill
our employees so i can't wait to hear
more about that kelly can you
go back and tell me how you even get
started with thinking about upskilling
as you know a main theme for your career
yeah absolutely well i you know i've
been in silicon valley my whole career
and started off in um in
engineering actually product development
and moved into corporate strategy
and then you know realized uh kind of
mid-career that i really wanted to do
something more meaningful and
impactful for me personally and that's
when i made the transition
into learning with really a focus on
that this intersection between
uh learning and technology and
uh as that's evolved now now the future
of work
so uh so my journey led me i actually
moved
when i was at sun microsystems moved
from an executive position in
corporate strategy into an executive
position in learning which was a great
opportunity
and then and then when oracle bought sun
i moved to yahoo and then linkedin
recruited me
and while i was at linkedin uh you know
that was
an amazing opportunity to start a
learning organization from the ground up
but also
i had a small development team where we
were actually building a learning
platform very much like degreed um in
its early stages but just for internal
employees and and in 2016 i joined
degree
because i really wanted to have an
impact on the industry not just for one
employee population and
i would say the learning in ed tech area
is even more important now than when i
first entered the field it's it's
booming it's changing it's driving so
much of
what businesses feel is important today
and that's
what led me to to the upskilling journey
which is what people are talking about
a lot today so can you know go
go 30 000 feet in the air with me and
then share with me a little bit about
this idea of learning in the workplace
because
until i actually spoke with you know
the ceo of learning i i didn't really
understand that there's this whole you
know
theme of you know working with employees
to empower them and help them
and upskill them so why what is it
and and why do we need it yeah i think
you know you have to go back to i mean
you made a comment earlier
uh when people traditionally graduated
from
university they felt like they had the
knowledge that they needed to take them
throughout
through the entirety of their careers
and we've seen
huge shift in the shifts in the way uh
the work
force in the world is um evolving right
now so you've got
acceleration which is you know how fast
things are moving you've got
automation you've got a.i you've got all
of these things converging
at once uh and we often call that the
fourth industrial
revolution so the reality of that in the
workplace
is that the old model of corporate
learning was saying
we're just gonna model what people were
doing in university so we're going to
design and develop some classroom-based
lecture based learning where we're
actually just giving people
knowledge and and helping them kind of
progress in their career but it wasn't a
huge focus in fact a lot of times it was
only
focused on managers and leaders or maybe
high potential employees
but we got to the point where we
realized uh everybody needs to be
building
skills continuously throughout the
entirety of their careers
and that's what upskilling is
fundamentally about and we know that
you know jobs are changing careers are
changing
and it's no longer this you know you
spend your whole career at one company
you're
you know you probably will i think that
the status is that for millennials
they'll have
15 uh jobs in their
in their lifetime and oftentimes not
even in the same field i
i know that's been my experience and
it's probably
many people's experience so how do you
how do you keep
learning how do you keep uh thinking
about uh
keeping your skills sharp and building
new skills
and that's so that's upskilling but it's
really
uh there's also reskilling people ask
you know what's the difference between
reskilling and upscaling
you know if you want to move into a
completely different area you need to
understand
you know what skills are required to be
successful in that area
if you're in a field like learning or
talent
it was five years ago you didn't need to
know about ai and machine learning or
big data
and all that uh you do now you cannot be
successful
running corporate learning or talent in
a company without
understanding those things so what what
do you do
you have to upskill or reskill yourself
you know
and take it on yourself to do that
amazing and so why is that why is that
difficult
why is it difficult for corporates to
you know upscale their workers and
provide them opportunities to
to you know build upon what they
normally know or what they know they
don't know
right i think one of the things that uh
we've learned and
uh you know i published a book with my
co-author david blake um
called the expertise economy uh it's
been about two years now
and one of the things uh that that we
realized
is is that people companies and
people themselves don't really think
about uh
what they're doing in their jobs in
relation to the skills that they have
even people coming out of college
they'll talk about what degree they have
but what how does that translate into
what skills they have
what can they actually do so the
fundamental problem that most companies
have is that they don't understand
the skills people have today or the
skills that people
need in the future and so uh you know
part of the whole
uh value proposition behind degreed is
to say let let us help you
through data understand uh what skills
people have and what skills they need so
that we know how to focus
it's it's this uh direction away from
this one-size-fits-all learning that we
know doesn't work
the lecture-based learning that doesn't
work we need to move to more
personalized learning based on what
people already know and what they
need to know uh the other thing i would
say about that is
that a lot of companies in the past were
really focused on
top down we're going to decide what
everybody needs to learn
right it's not a very good strategy
right and so
now it's flipped to say you know work we
have this data and really
you as an individual should know i
should know what skills do i have
and if i'm thinking about my career
aspirations what should i be thinking
about in terms of what skills i need to
build
in order to stay competitive in the
market
so companies need to to understand it to
stay competitive and
individuals need to understand it to
stay competitive as well
so yeah i'm trying to put myself in the
shoes of you know
ceo or a manager in the leadership role
in a big company and i'm trying to think
okay so i so okay so i buy into this
idea that
i want to upskill my employees it'll
improve attention or improve their
you know their ability to to to move
around within the company understanding
that people want to transition
and learn different skill sets and
that's part of the problem of the churn
that we have but now i'm thinking okay
well how do i actually go about and do
this
you know i'm you know i potentially
having 100 people
every person needs to be upskilled in a
different way what resources do i have
to have to
be able to execute on on this mission
right so the approach we're taking is
really saying you know you you can start
with the employees you have i would say
in the old model of work it used to be
when a company wanted to go after a new
market opportunity they would decide
what that market opportunity was and
what kind of talent they would need to
actually pursue
that um talent we know in the in the
industry is getting harder and harder to
get because everybody's competing for
the same talent
companies that used to consider
themselves
uh financial uh companies are now
considering themselves
tech companies and everybody wants data
scientists right
so it's not it's not as if you can just
go and readily
get uh all the top data scientists that
you want because you're competing with
companies the biggest companies in the
world amazon and google and all those
companies so
what do you do um so the strategy is
really to say
how can i help you know hopefully you've
hired some really smart people into your
company
that can learn new skills instead of
just
uh you know uh
figuring out a hiring strategy what
about a
and i think it's a hybrid strategy right
it's like yes you can still hire
external people but i don't think you
can depend on that completely
how about if we take people inside of
our company find out who's got
you know the desire and some of the
basic skills to
move in that direction and then let's
have
uh um initiatives around company-wide
initiatives around that
i'd say booz allen hamilton is a great
example where they
data science was the example where they
said you know what
we have clients that are asking us for
uh
data scientists every day and we don't
have enough for today
to fill that need so imagine three years
from now
and so they actually put together a data
science 5k
program where they said look we're going
to try to
develop our own talent in these skills
and i think that that's a great way to
start but you can't do that unless you
know
again what skills people have and what
skills they need that's the starting
point
and how do you actually gauge that in a
systematic way i'm guessing that
you know if you part of the issue that
you'll that you'll reach is saying okay
well
so i know that i want to empower my
employees and upskill them but
you know they may not know what it what
it is they're interested in
and i for sure don't know for them and i
have a lot of these employees so how do
i actually how do you systematically
then work on giving a personalized
experience to each one
so that's a great question and in fact a
few months ago i just wrote a white
paper
called the seven steps for upskilling
your workforce
and one of the things that we recommend
is that
you really start with um with
identifying
working with the business leaders in the
company to identify
what are those key critical skills that
we think we're going to need in the
future
so you can take it from two to um
angles if if you're looking at it from a
business perspective you're going to say
i want to give my employees guidance
these are the top skills uh in fact i
i worked pretty extensively with the
leaders at cisco
and at unilever to do to run this
process
and to say um you know what skills do we
think we're going to need in the future
and then let's get our employees and we
have this uh
there's various ways that you can
measure skills
for employees and degreed we have a way
that you can actually
uh measure people's skills based on the
lumina foundation but there's lots of
other skills right there's
signals from credly on badges there's
your
your actual degrees that you got from
school there's other credentials you
know stanford has a bunch of
um certificate programs for that i mean
there's a variety of signals that you
can get about where
what skills people have and where they
are there once uh you ask people to
assess themselves based on the skills
that are most important for the company
and for the individual so say you
identify five critical skills for the
company moving forward
maybe the individual based on their
career goals
wants to focus on two of those five and
then
they assess their skills based on that
figure out where they're at
and then we also have a target range for
certain opportunities so
they say oh great i need i need to build
my skills in
in this particular area and then they
can get learning
in order to a variety of learning in
order to
gain those skills and then they can
reassess and see how they're making
progress
and i think one of the most important
things is data
data and insights around how people are
learning and building skills
so that you can show the progress you
know and you it's so
important to get that baseline of where
people start
um so that then you can pick it sounds
so simple right
so then you can then um you know compare
it against
when they learn to learn some things are
they making progress
and once you've done that you can get um
you know both the individual can see
these are the skills i'm focusing on
this is the progress
i'm making and then from a business
level from a group level you can say
oh this is how we're progressing so
given the example
uh you know for at booz allen that you
know if their goal was
5 000 people up skilled in data science
how are they doing you know how can they
measure that that that's how they're
doing it
so it's really about data analytics
insights and then measuring that
at uh both the individual level and at
the group
and company level so you have you know
that view at all three levels
so what's first of all it sounds you
know amazing and it sounds
incredibly complicated at the same time
because a lot of these things are you
know they are
a lot of these things are subjective
some of them are objective but
but then also when you measure you know
it depends the comparisons are
getting interesting and i think that at
the end you know there's different
motivations obviously
for upskilling but you know the core of
it i think from what i
want to hear from you you know it is
beneficial for a company like booze and
now
okay we we need we need you know more
data scientists i'm sure that also
obviously the
newly educated data scientists are very
happy with it
and obviously it has a big butterfly
effect
on the churn on the engagement on the
you know
the trust that is being built what has
been the most challenging
piece of integration that you've
observed
you know that you know patterns that
you're seeing across the different
organizations
that you work with uh
so i i think one of the things is and
you mentioned it uh just a moment ago
that it seems uh complicated and complex
but it doesn't have to be right i mean i
think that what
uh where where people get bogged down
is when they try to say look we want to
identify every skill that every person
might have and
then have people assess against all of
those skills and
you know it becomes overwhelming it's
kind of if you look at
the old uh competency models in hr
that you know become so overwhelming
that those projects never
for anybody who's been involved in any
of those projects they're outdated
before you even finish them
so the the that's that's what you have
to resist
at a company is is trying to take too
much on so in
in the guide what we recommend is for
individuals really
focus on one skill and uh for companies
only identify
three to five skills that are going to
be really important so you have some
sort of focus so people don't feel
overwhelmed because think about
how many skills can you realistically
focus on at any given
time right so i think simplicity is key
and that don't make you can make it very
complex and
complicated but if you resist that and
make it very simple and just start
because
think of where we are today if people
don't really even know
the skills they have or the skills they
need just having a simple baseline with
some target skills
brings us so much uh further than we
ever have been
before and then we can build and evolve
on that
i love that hayley why why are you
spending you know
your career on this what what is it
about upskilling learning that really
gets you excited well you know it's
a great question and i think one of the
things is is that i've been
uh as i mentioned at the beginning of
this
of our discussion is that i've been in
silicon valley my whole career
and i was shocked when i got into the
learning field that
that things were so antiquated and that
we couldn't
figure out how to use everything
that we have available to us in order to
make this
better and simple and to change people's
mindsets that's been one of the biggest
challenges and what i've been spending
that's why we wrote the book that's why
i'm on the road well
virtually now but uh speaking to people
about
these and you know the future of work
and how we should be reimagining work
and how we do things it's not a small
thing but we're changing the industry
right by
by uh evolving how people think about
learning and work
and uh and getting new opportunities i
think the other thing
that you know we haven't talked about
yet but um
the other part of this whole skill
upskilling journey
is really to help people get uh
opportunities right because at the end
of the day
if people want to figure out how they
can
uh they can get a new opportunity if you
can tie
what people are learning to the skills
they're building then
show them opportunities that might be
available to them based on the skills
that they have
to me that's uh nirvana that's what
most people individuals want and i think
companies want and so
it's uh that that talent marketplace
based on
skills as the currency of the future of
work
that's i think that where where
everything is headed
and uh so i'm i'm spending my career on
it because i think it's incredibly
important and
i think uh i think it's making a
difference in the world
i love it i i really really love it and
i think that the mission is wonderful
and i think that
you know obviously the impact that
you've had on the different
organizations is amazing and i
especially love you understanding that
okay you're
you're solving it internally for some
organizations but really this is an
industry-wide phenomenon that needs to
be
needs to be resolved and there aren't
enough people that are doing it so you
pick up the glove and you go and do it
and you make that impact you know
industry-wide
and obviously not not only just you know
advising companies but also
you know helping vc fund invested
companies that are working on the future
of work and so really it's a whole new
vertical that is
just really you know i've only heard
about this ideal future of work and
really in the past year or two from my
end so i think
it is very new and i think it's very
very exciting thank you for being so
generous with your
time and the last question thank you the
most important one that i have
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh passionate uh
driven and uh
and impactful i love it kelly
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy continue making a
positive impact
thank you so much thanks for having me